je fais des bras des doigts des trucs
atroces franchement j'ai vu je suis pas
fière de ça mais ça me ça me rend folle
parce que on frôle la mort en plus on
scooter
un doigt en général avec un sourire ça
suffit amplement
[Applaudissements]
j'aime mieux avec les cheveux longs
c'est un moment vous aviez les cheveux
courts
c'est que vous êtes le sosie d'une des
femmes de Frédéric tu trouves pas que
c'est une sosie Delphine Frédéric c'est
le même genre c'est le même style
et c'était justement alors pour faire
cet enfant
voilà alors Zazie votre album rodéo est
dans les bacs depuis fin novembre ça
marche bien ça marche d'autant mieux que
c'est un sacré truc il y a une version
CD et puis une version CD plus tu vas
regarder tu imagines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
virtuel on se sert d'un nom d'une image
d'un truc complètement qui n'existe pas
elle suit les Beatles à la trace
il y a toujours dans une carrière de
rockstar il y a toujours une étape où il
faut passer par l'Inde pour se
ressourcer et trouver la sagesse de
notre humanité et on est tous un peu
indien aussi je veux dire si on repart
de géographie pure le continent c'est
scindé après mais j'y ai vraiment trouvé
des résonances sans du tout me convertir
ni à l'hindouisme ni à la pauvreté ni à
des choses qui qui m'échappent vraiment
j'ai trouvé des résonances à
non pas un rôle mais en tant que fille
je crois que quand on quand on parle de
du monde ou des autres on est très dans
le détail dans le point de son goût du
tiroir ou éventuellement le type qui va
pas mais qui est sur le trottoir d'en
face quoi on est on est très dans on a
ce souci du détail en Inde on peut pas
avoir des solutions de détails on peut
pas avoir des solutions individuelles on
a envie d'en adopter un puis dispute 15
puissance donc c'est pas possible il
faut trouver d'autres choses donc c'est
intéressant on commence au début on
commence à se dire c'est atroce vraiment
parce qu'on n'a pas été préparé parce
que découvrir l'un à 40 ans c'est un
traumatisme quand on est bien bobo chez
soi
gentille tout plein avec des des
problèmes de riches quoi
et donc au début c'est assez
insupportable aussi en tant que maman
c'est insupportable parce qu'on était
moins de choses qui sont vraiment
atroces et on peut pas zapper on n'est
pas à la télé et puis et puis on et puis
la troisième semaine on cesse de de
réfléchir en
occidental et c'est ça qui est
intéressant là-bas c'est la remise en
perspective je ne peux même pas vous
dire exactement ce que j'y ai appris je
sais que je suis simplement revenu de ce
pays avec une force incroyable voilà
alors il va y avoir le rodéo tour début
juin
pour une fois ah oui vous c'est où
le 16 et le 17 septembre la dernière
fois c'est de sa faute en plus donc j'en
profite
la dernière fois je vous avais invité et
vous vous étiez censé venir vous aviez
même réservé vous allez laisser une
belle table super bien au Bataclan et
puis et puis celui-là il a eu l'idée de
se marier ce qui est une bonne idée en
soi et voilà il vous étiez témoin et
donc vous n'êtes pas venu
le problème avec lui c'est qui se
marquent
donc si vous pouviez éviter de vous
marier
il y a toute une tournée l'été etc 16 17
septembre à Bercy si tu pouvais éviter
de te marier le 16 ou 17 septembre
très personnel donc vous avez écrit
toutes les paroles des textes un peu un
peu sombre quand même avec beaucoup de
questions sur le sur le couple ma chère
Zazie genre ça va t'intéresser toi
faut-il se prendre continuellement le
chou
dans un couple ou partir du jour au
lendemain si on tu vois où on s'engueule
un peu tous les jours on s'engueule une
bonne fois pour tout
me permettre que c'est une très très
bonne question
mais aimer en fait il faut pas ne jamais
s'engueuler mais quand ça devient 24
heures sur 24 ça n'est pas très sain non
plus non on est d'accord il y a pas trop
de scène en ce moment si il y en a mais
elles font partie de du bonheur du
piquant aussi c'était pour savoir si
tout allait bien
Dolce Vita ça va t'intéresser Frédéric
voilà le couple une fois que la patience
est un peu estompé qu'est-ce qui se
passe tu vois c'est
mais c'est pas moi qui ai fait ce disque
c'est
vraiment je pense que c'est comme dans
tout c'est un combat de tous les jours
et
c'est voilà
c'est vrai on passe vachement de temps à
travailler on passe vachement de temps à
faire des albums ou associer ou cela et
puissent plus
ce que tu veux dire c'est qu'en fait on
se donne beaucoup de mal pour plein de
trucs sauf pour l'amour qui devrait être
préoccupation en fait finalement c'est
peut-être aussi le truc dans lequel on
est le moins doué donc ce serait bien
qu'on travaille un peu plus quoi mais
s'il faut travailler ça devient
tu penses ça Gilbert toi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Gilbert est capable de faire court
Laurent très court la preuve la preuve
c'est fini voilà vous êtes pas marié
avec Fabien vous hein
par exemple qui qui pour moi bon après
c'est très personnel à chacun mais
le fait de savoir que l'un ou l'autre
peut se barrer du jour au lendemain
donne quand même une espèce de notion de
aussi c'est vrai
donc c'est pareil finalement se barrer
c'est bien beau mais quand on a un môme
c'est pareil et puis c'est pas rien
fromage et dessert
quel clip de slow où vous embrassez une
fille Zazie dis donc qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé
la prise 4 fois l'enfoiré
non mais alors le seul truc franchement
c'est pas c'est pas du tout mon truc
mais par contre c'est vrai que j'ai
trouvé l'élève d'une fille très douce
c'est vrai que c'est doux on imagine pas
quand on l'a jamais fait voilà mais ça
m'a pas provoqué un truc de dingue voilà
quoi
j'essaye de placer le mot Amazon ça me
va bien c'est vrai que vous êtes passé
de mannequin à Amazon une certaine façon
en terme de de type de femme vous dites
la part de garçon en moi c'est une
manière d'être encore plus près des
hommes
je pense vous admettez que vous avez
quand même une part garçon importante
être un garçon manqué c'est j'espère
être une fille réussie quoi donc c'est
pas c'est vrai c'est pas grave
c'est vrai que très longtemps quand
j'étais petite j'étais j'essaie d'être
un garçon pour être en fait vachement au
contact avec les avec les garçons et ça
a vachement bien marché parce que je les
voyais en plus par le trou de la serrure
si je peux me permettre et c'était
c'était très intéressant comme comme
fille de pouvoir avoir accès à à ces
choses-là sauf qu'au bout d'un moment
quand il prenait pour qu'on finance
j'étais là mon cœur battait à sent à
l'heure comme n'importe quelle fille à
la vanille et puis disait dis donc je
peux l'embrasser celle-là elle a d'un
coup ça se voilà j'étais fine en plus
tu deviens trop ami très bon je crois
que c'est le moment de faire une
interview c'est que ce fort
est-ce que vous savez changer une roue
est-ce que chaque année vous allez au
Salon de l'Auto non est-ce que vous avez
sifflet avec vos doigts
de Michael Jackson est-ce que vous non
j'étais loin donc je me voyais pas donc
du coup est-ce que vous êtes forte
est-ce que vous réussissez vos créneaux
du premier coup je n'ai pas mon permis
donc même pas en rêve vous devenez pas
vulgaire au volant si au volant de votre
scooter vous pouvez être vulgaire
extrêmement vulgaire c'est pour ça que
je passe pas mon permis parce que je
pense que je veux je vais me faire
définitivement horreur quoi c'est
vraiment je suis poissonnier
je suis pas fière de ça mais ça me rend
pas on frôle la mort en plus
est-ce que vous arrive de regarder un
match de foot en buvant une bière
oui
est-ce que vous mettez le réveil le
dimanche matin pour Téléfoot non jamais
vous avez déjà mis la main au cul d'un
mec
dans une chanson oui
vous avez déjà offert un verre dans une
boîte de nuit un bel inconnu oui j'ai
déjà embrassé un bel inconnu comme ça en
un endroit vers lui en disant que c'est
dommage qui partent parce qu'il avait
mis ça manteau vous êtes capable de
coucher sans sentiment
je l'ai fait je l'ai fait comme
expérience
franchement j'étais en larmes le
lendemain donc je suis pas capable
pour ça je pense est-ce que vous avez
déjà tout fait
pour qu'un mec vous largue
non jamais
j'ai oublié la date des anniversaires de
vos mecs 18 avril
la force des béliers tranquilles
avec toi
non non j'ai déjà sorti avec deux frères
enfin pas en même temps
le père le fils
vous êtes toujours des préservatifs sur
vous au cas où
non bah non parce que franchement je
suis assez amoureuse donc
vous êtes capable de dire je t'aime sans
le penser
par contre je suis capable de le dire en
argument et pas se dire le plus beau je
t'aime c'est celui qui compte Mon
gratuit qui sera à rien qui a voilà et
c'est vrai que le je t'aime est quand
même un petit peu sert un peu de
fourre-tout parfois mais je t'aime enfin
voilà pour argumenter donc celui-là ils
sont ils sont pas jolis
[Rires]
est-ce que vous avez déjà profité qu'un
mec soit bourré pour coucher avec lui
mais mais quand je bois je suis bien
enfin je suis un peu en forme aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est quoi ça moi je m'en tire bien
franchement enfin je vais pas y arriver
mais vous devez essayer de lécher votre
coude c'est très facile je peux pas
c'est impossible j'ai des coups trop
grand
pour être sûr de ne rien rater
un pouce bleu